so what I'd like to do is to think about
the ways in which there are three
components of urbanism that link the
past in the present the real building
blocks of urbanism are primarily people
places and the resultant possibilities
even though we might think that the
cities of the ancient world and the
cities of today must have been so very
different because we have electricity
and they didn't and we have Bart and
they didn't what I can say is that in
those categories of people places and
possibilities modern and ancient cities
were exactly the same so there are a
number of ways that we can sort of peel
back those layers of time and think
about how urban continuities
how the idea of being an urban animal is
something that is now with us and is
going to be with us forever or at least
the next 10,000 years
so water what do modern and ancient
cities have in common first of all
there's monumental architecture that
sense of people building things that are
much greater than what any particular
family would need or what any community
would need for any kind of temporary
purpose what we have is monumental
architecture that is often functional
sometimes entirely symbolic like quite
Tower or the Eiffel Tower or any of
those other kinds of towers but it's the
capacity to make and imagine large-scale
structures that really links the past
and the present
another thing that cities have in common
all over the world are divisions of
labor so even though we often think
about Adam Smith and The Wealth of
Nations as describing how it is that we
can have more efficient production
processes by dividing labor and having
people specialize in tasks this is
something that smart managers knew 6,000
years ago as well we can see in the
world that there were firings of kilns
to produce ceramic vessels twenty to
twenty-five thousand pieces at a time so
this massive quantities of production
and consumption and also discard is
something that we can clearly see every
urban settlement past or present another
thing that we get in both modern and
ancient cities are the diverse economies
that characterize the migrations of
people coming in and the specialties of
different kinds of activities that
people are willing to take a chance on a
long time ago the archaeologist V Gordon
Child talked about how being in a city
was a godsend for somebody who was
manufacturing something like metal tools
that farmers might need only once or
twice a year so they couldn't keep
somebody like that in a village they had
to have this itinerant way of life until
cities came up and made it possible for
somebody to produce something very
utilitarian or even very esoteric and be
able to have customers every single day
coming to them so this is why cities are
places of innovation and when you think
about Fashion Week Fashion Week is
always in a city when you think about
tech innovations they're almost always
in cities so that that large number of
producers is met by a large number of
consumers we also get urban planning as
something that we find in every urban
settlement past and present and
oftentimes archeologists have looked
only at kind of the downtown areas of
ancient settlements where that sense of
planning is the most regularized we're
only now starting to look at some of the
outlying areas where planning is often
escaped by the people who live in them
so suburban areas and slum areas of
ancient cities are places where we can
see that the urban planning ethos is not
quite reached just as we have the same
concerns for our own
cities both here in the US and in other
places as well we get extensive
hinterlands so that the products that
come into urban settlements might come
from an enormous distance and yet as a
consumer you know that when you go to a
market you will be able to find what you
need whether it's an apple from Belgium
or an apple from New Zealand or an apple
from Shasta County you know as a
consumer all these pathways of
transportation bring things to you that
you want and need from that diverse and
often distant hinterland and finally
it's the social networks that make it
possible for people in cities to
interact to interact with their
neighbors to interact with their friends
and also very importantly to interact
with strangers